today
pretty much every economy in the world
is organized along capitalist lines
but at the same time capitalism is
almost everywhere regarded with
disappointment
frustration and suspicion interestingly
none of the criticisms are new
they've been dogging capitalism since
its inception
so let's look back in time to figure out
how capitalism got its bad name
and what might be done to improve it
padua
italy 1304 on the wall of a church in
padua near venice
the painter giotto makes a fresco jesus
and the money lenders
it restates for his own times an idea
that had by then already been well
established for centuries in the west
the notion that a good spiritual life
and the pursuit of business and money
are sworn enemies jesus goes to the
temple in jerusalem
sees merchants and small-time bankers
crowding the forecourt and gets furious
this sacred place is not a fitting arena
for the polluting activities
of buying and selling the christian
attack on the immorality of money is
deeply influential
and severely holds back the development
of capitalism
for centuries venice 1450
a franciscan friar luca pacioli
publishes the first ever book on
accounting
summa de arithmetica it's the single
most important capitalist invention
until the birth of the joint stock
company and the modern factory
in the book pacioli introduces the
principle of double entry bookkeeping
which gradually becomes standard
practice in all companies
pacioli's textbook proposes that dealing
well with money
doesn't depend on fate anymore money
isn't a divine punishment or reward
it's a kind of science that can be
learnt through patience
reason and hard work
geneva 1555 in powerful sermons to his
congregations in geneva
the protestant theologian john calvin
emphasizes to his swiss audiences
the importance of what have become known
as the protestant virtues
hard work self-denial patience honesty
and duty
these will turn out to be extremely
useful qualities for capitalism
calvin along with many other preachers
who share his outlook
explains that you must never indulge
yourself nor spend money having a lavish
life
you must simply put any surplus income
back into your business as an investment
calvin adds that being good at business
is far more pleasing in the sight of god
than being an aristocratic warrior or
even a monk
perhaps more than technology it's this
new mindset
that will accelerate the progress of
capitalism
1670 delft dutch republic the newly
independent dutch republic is the
world's
first explicitly capitalist nation where
lazy aristocrats
are looked down upon and hardworking
merchants revered
in the churches protestant sermons about
thrift and hard work are heard in the
arts
outgo glorifications of kings and queens
johannes vermeer
finishes painting the lace maker a
depiction of the intricate
careful and homely tasks of
manufacturing lace
in his painting the little street the
suggestion is that living peacefully and
quietly in your own home
running a business is far more glamorous
and noble
than fighting in a war or going to a
monastery
1776 141 the strand london
these are the offices and shop of strain
and cable publishers
who have a big success with a new book
an inquiry into the nature and causes of
the wealth of nations
written by a scottish philosopher called
adam smith
smith demystifies wealth creation by
explaining how capitalist economies grow
he reaches several important conclusions
slavery
is remarkably inefficient violence is
less of an incentive than money
for a worker and the cost of buying and
maintaining slaves
far exceeds the cost of wages
capitalists will make far more money
by treating their workers legally and
humanely
it's by specializing that economies grow
says smith
smith focuses on the pin making industry
and concludes that while one worker
could make up to 20 pins a day a team of
10 workers well arranged
could make not 248 000 pins
thanks to what smith terms the division
of labor
smith also tells us that capitalism is
guided by an invisible hand
by maximizing one's own profit
individuals inadvertently benefit
society
providing goods that people want and
need as smith puts it
it is not from the benevolence of the
butcher the brewer or the baker
that we expect our dinner but from their
regard to their own
self-interest these ideas further remove
the moral suspicion
that once surrounds capitalism but not
all will be won over
1854 london the british economy
is now the largest in the world thanks
to its enormous industries of cotton
shipbuilding steel and coal
vast cities have chewed up the
countryside of the midlands and northern
england
merchants and the newly rich capitalist
class have triumphed
but many are furious charles dickens one
of victorian england's most passionate
critics of unrestrained capitalism
publishes a novel hard times set in the
fictional town of coketown
a version of manchester it takes aim at
heartless capitalists
like mr grad grind who abuse their
workers exploit young children in mines
and chimneys
and use their relentless capitalist
logic to blind them to their desecration
of nature and human life
here is dickens writing on coke town it
was a town of red brick or of brick that
would have been red
if the smoke and ashes had allowed it
but as mata stood
it was a town of unnatural red and black
like the painted face of a savage
dickens argues that capitalism is evil
because it encourages appalling
conditions for the producers
under the sway of capitalist logic
otherwise quite nice people will keep
coming up with reasons
why it's okay to employ a child in a
factory or to let poor people starve
once they've reached the end of their
working lives
1860 london the english reformer john
ruskin
publishes unto this last a furious tract
against
capitalism that takes aim not so much at
the production side of capitalism
as the area of consumption like dickens
ruskin is incensed that people are being
exploited and the environment ruined
but he asks a further question in the
name of what
ruskin notes that large capitalist
fortunes are built upon selling people
absurd things knickknacks fancy plates
embroidered napkins
bonnets carved sideboards the whole of
the suffering of the cotton factories of
manchester
are being fed by our appetite for very
cheap shirts with delicate collars
we are ruining our lives for trinkets
whereas for ruskin
money shouldn't only be made morally it
should be spent morally
on the truly noble and beautiful things
that humans need
he contrasts the beauty of venice with
the ugliness of modern britain to make
his point
berlin 1963 the leader of communist east
germany
walter ulbricht launches an ambitious
new scheme the neues economischer system
or nos it aims to solve for east germans
the two major failings of capitalism in
his eyes
one it will guarantee workers good
conditions with a huge expansion in the
number of state schools
housing blocks and holiday camps and
secondly it will focus not on the
fripperies of capitalist production
like blue jeans and pop music it will
give people the works of plato and marx
and uplifting television programs about
tractor production
1976 dresden east germany the fatal
flaws of communism come to a head in
january
with a massive riot about the
unavailability of coffee
east germans love drinking coffee but a
huge rise in global prices
means that the german democratic
republic can no longer afford
to import it in the necessary quantities
the politburo
decides to remove all coffee from shops
and replaces it with
mish cafe mixed coffee which is 51
coffee and 49 a range of fillers
including chicory
rye and sugar beet dissatisfaction with
this eventually has to be quelled with
the use of the stasi or secret police
it's an inadvertent tribute to
capitalism which is especially good at
providing us
with life's little luxuries edeka hyper
market near hamburg
november 1989 east germans who have
recently breached the wall
head straight for west german
supermarkets like edeka near hamburg
they marvel at the productive capacities
of capitalism
and at the ability that it has to
provide such modest but very important
things as
olive oil party hats ice buns and coffee
the old east german elite who would
believe that the people could be
satisfied with philosophy
athletics sauerkraut and tv programs
about farming
are hounded out of office
1999 seattle usa the world trade
organization a capitalist body
dedicated to removing protection from
industry and liberalizing markets
gets together for its next round of
talks ten years
since the fall of communism and after a
decade of unprecedented economic growth
but though the mood of politicians is
upbeat out in the streets
hundreds of thousands of anti-capitalist
protesters have gathered to call an
end to the iniquities of global
capitalism the complaints are strikingly
similar
to those made by jesus christ capitalism
doesn't look after the producers
and capitalism downgrades the important
spiritual ends of life
for the sake of hamburgers unsustainably
cheap clothes
and garish distracting mass media with
their beards and gaunt figures
many of the protesters look a little
like renaissance renditions of jesus
the police take a very heavy hand fire
tear gas into the crowds
arrest two thousand and call in the
national guard
the protests remind the world that
besides the winners of capitalism
there is an enormous army of the
disenfranchised and the angry
who see more sense in jesus dickens and
ruskin than in adam smith and bill
clinton
2015 cupertino california apple
computers
officially becomes the largest
corporation in the world it's a giant
success story
but the very same challenges remain it
turns out that apple are indirectly
responsible for the suffering and abuse
of workers
in the supply chain in china via the
foxconn corporation
and with the launch of the apple watch a
gadget that seems to have no
particularly urgent purpose
questions are once again raised about
why we're exhausting ourselves and the
planet
for ends that are so out of proportion
with the costs they impose on all of us
to generalize capitalism is amazingly
productive but it has two
big flaws firstly it's systematically
inclined to ignore the sufferings of
workers
unless regularly prodded not to and the
wealth of companies
is often built up on satisfying what are
not the essential needs of human beings
fortunes are made on making unhealthy
food or bad television programs
the challenge for the future is how we
might be able to make money
humanely by treating people and the
earth well
and also make money through activities
which address
the more noble end of human needs till
then
the rage of jesus in the temple will
periodically
always go on
you